one of the lessons is that when chaos
strikes
you're on your own our new documentary
series tucker carlson originals the new
episode takes a look at how
americans have survived periods of
anarchy it's a fascinating
fascinating piece of film you can watch
it on foxnation.com
right now we've been wondering for a
while how
voter identification is racist all the
polls show that americans of
all colors think you ought to be
required to show id
prove you're you when you vote well
kamala harris has said many times it's
racist and on friday she spelled out
exactly how it is watch
is agreeing to voter id one of those
compromises that you'd support
i don't think that we should
underestimate what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um xerox or
photocopy your id to send it in to prove
you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinko's there's no office max near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it almost
impossible for them to prove who they
are
in rural areas to which i've never been
they can't get to kinko's
is there any kind goes anywhere does
kiko's even exist do you think the
blockbuster too
tammy bruce keeps track of america's
retail landscape she's the host of
another show you should watch on fox
nation called get tammy bruce and we're
happy to have her join us tonight
so tammy let's say you live in a rural
area the place that
kamalaris has never been how hard is it
to get to a kinkos right now would you
say
yeah you know i'll tell you there is
someone and kamala may
know this best because she can't find
her job right she has no idea where that
is
she doesn't know what it entails she
doesn't know what to do with it she
can't do diplomacy she doesn't
know how to answer questions so it's
kamala harris who doesn't understand
where things are uh the fact is of
course it's it's
we can joke about harris she doesn't
clearly know
america at all i would argue a rural
america
can of course they're running businesses
they run
farms they feed the world uh they're
just like in urban areas there may be
some economic problems people of all
different colors
but the question here is besides the
insult of it
is why are the democrats so desperate to
make cheating
easier this is what's amazing and the
the monmouth poll you
uh mentioned the polling last month 68
percent of
62 percent of democrats want voter id 87
of independence and 91 of the gop
no one wants what they're saying and yet
they're so desperate now
they're saying you can't do it like the
world people by the way also they're
trump voters
uh we're told they're vaccine resistors
uh they
invaded and the in insurrection in
january
uh so they're complicated people but
they've done all of this without an
office max
i i don't know how they could be capable
of doing all of that
but i think that this is a sign of of
the democrats now
grasping at straws to try to keep people
from being able to uh
know their vote is safe that's it's a
problem yeah if you're not for voter id
then we can assume sinister intent i
think there's no
absolutely nothing about that tammy
bruce great to see you tonight thank you
thank you sir hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else